Tom Crean joining us the ESPN college
basketball analyst had Kansas in
Oklahoma last night he'll be in studio
starting tonight through Saturday big 12
SEC challenge is all day on Saturday
Continental Tire Coach's Corner hi coach
how are you I'm doing great dance good
to be with you is great to hear that
stat right there to about Robert Parish
that's great yeah but people forget he
spent so many ton so much time in Boston
but I think he also was with the Bulls
too late late in his career did you uh
did you have a favorite who's your
favorite player growing up oh it had to
be a piston it just kind of depended
when I was growing up it depended on
what piston was playing the best but I
would say my overall was probably John
Havlicek because I got to see him play
when I was a kid and it was the night
that he set the record for consecutive
games to be that was that that was a big
big deal so I would go with him but I
loved the Pistons John been dealt
Kevin Porter people like that John
mangled John crash Mendel how was I was
into that I he he may have led the
nation in scoring or one of the top
scorers at Auburn right I think he went
to Auburn I think so yeah and I start
following when he was with the Bulls and
then he was a piston so really where I
grew up though the overall greatest was
magic to me because growing up in that
area I was I was a little 12 I think
when they won the national championship
so you have to put him at the top of the
list but when it came to MBA guys that
would have been my group who's the best
player you've ever coached against I've
ever coached against oh well that's a
good question
they played the best back in it back in
the old Conference USA it would have
been guys like Reece Gaines you played
for Rick at Louisville it would have
been Steve Logan who played at
Cincinnati I think those guys were so
hard to deal with but I don't know if I
have a player playing against Kansas in
the 2003 Final Four they had no
weaknesses and we and I've never seen
anybody that could do that they had the
speed to get the ball up the court that
we had faced like Kirk Hinrich or a guy
that was a forward that could run like
Nick Collison so I would probably go off
the top of my
that I'd go with that Kansas group and
those two guys being the hardest to deal
with let's turn our attention to last
night's game and I thought Bill Self
made a really big coaching mistake by
leaving his big man in there and
allowing Oklahoma to just give up fouls
and exchange a missed free-throw for
trying to make a two or three at the
other end your thought on that
philosophy there well I thought about
that a lot even this morning you know in
looking at that and I got caught up in
see I thought he was the whole key to
the game and in the first half when he
wasn't in there with the files that
allowed Oklahoma to play he's become so
good and not only been able to score on
the block but to find cutters and
passers and it was an incredible
strategy by lon
so in retrospect probably should have
got him out maybe two possessions
earlier but the thing that concerned me
more was that they were going to the
foul line and he had two offensive
rebounders on the foul line and none of
those guys ever made the attempt to
rebound in this free throw you know so
at the time it's you're not believing
that he's going to miss all of his free
throws and it's really hard you don't
want to take the confidence of the guy
and destroy him for somewhere down the
line and if he starts to hit a couple
free throws we're not even having a
conversation but never making an attempt
to rebound the misses even give him a
chance to have a second shot opportunity
was what would be milder to me and I
think that's on the players for not
going hard to the glass what he took
those shots not anticipating how do you
explain big men who can't shoot free
throws like at some point and he played
four years of high school and he's been
at Kansas what two years like I got a
go-to underhand coach because I what I'm
seeing there is that that's just a
terrible form and they probably worked
with him and it got it like it's better
but why not underhand for somebody like
him well I don't know that I think that
becomes you got to have a ton I mean
it's easy for the berries because
they've grown up in it but you've got to
have a ton of self-confidence to attempt
a shot like that in a game with a crowd
of people and I think it's a lot easier
to look at it and think it'd be a good
strategy and a lot harder to employ but
I've always tried to do like four you're
right he's got to change it's
I mean he turns his hand yes and he
really doesn't give him a chance to make
the shot but every time that you know
we've tried to work on different
techniques with balance with breathing
you're certainly the follow-through but
we used to spend more time when we had
guys that were stronger at the line
talking about being in position to
rebound the ball okay not saying hey we
know he's gonna miss focus on his shot
get them thinking about rebounding the
best and we actually be Louisville one
time when I was at Marquette because our
guys were so ingrained we had a free
throw shooter up that hit but that was
struggling shooting the ball and because
he came off the front of the rim we had
a certain technique that we were using
we called it a quick flip we wanted to
come with me inside foot you know
there's a lot of different ways to coach
free-throw rebounded but we just came
straight in and we ended up getting a
tip then an event is helping to helped
us win the game so I always go to the
counter point of that work with the guy
individually to try to give them
confidence focus on his breathing focus
on his follow-through but get your guys
thinking we're going to be on a frenzy
to rebound the ball when it goes up do
you believe that big men have a
disadvantage when it comes to shooting
free throws no not at all I think it all
becomes because there's because it's
because it's so much about balance and
feet and and to me anybody that shoots a
hard ball right and like last night
don't shoot so hard ball that ball is
coming off his hand hard when you shoot
a hard ball it doesn't matter if you're
a guard or a big man you're gonna have a
hard time bacon shots when you can get
the ball off it arc on it you know have
kind of a softer touch and and you have
good feet and you've got balance you can
be a good shooter I mean it's certainly
not affected that Dirk Nowitzki czar the
world and people like that because the
ball always looks like it's going in and
when it misses it doesn't miss law so
I've been more of a believer in how you
shoot it how you release it what your
what your footwork is like you know how
you shift your weight at the free-throw
line and I don't think that's I don't
think that is now that the place where
that becomes harder bigger hands right
when guys get the ball back in their
palm which certainly you're going to get
with big men that can be a real problem
and so you got to get them to have that
fingertip control which is easier said
than done so that would be the place
where what you're asking I would
definitely agree with but the rest of it
I think it's all those other attributes
of shooting that come into it he's Tom
Crean ESPN college basketball analyst in
studio starting tonight through Saturday
big 12 SCC challenge is all day on
Saturday
watching Trey young and I've watched
probably five complete games this year
and I loved what I saw last night
because I think that's how he should be
he should not I thought it was
embarrassing and really a terrible
performance by him when he put up 39
shots over the weekend I get just they
weren't good shots you know he shows no
confidence in his teammates and then
last night I just love that he was more
economical got his numbers got to the
line got everybody involved and they're
far more dangerous team your thoughts on
what you saw with with Jung last night
compared to other games in this season
well from a coach's mind I would say
that what LAN did last night was
outstanding I mean the strategies the
way that they played but whatever he got
done in practice and in the film room
was even better and because what he got
a young guy to do and from every account
we weren't involved in the recruiting
but from every account he is way beyond
his years security wise certainly got a
sense out of conversation with him about
doing the Wichita State game about what
he sees inside pick-and-roll and what
he's looking at and his advanced vision
his visions incredible young got gifts
but his advanced ability to read how the
defense is playing is something there's
guys in the NBA that don't have I know
I've had guys were in the NBA now that
were two years in seniors before they
got a level of that so I think you're
absolutely right what lon did to get him
to absorb that he needed to play better
what he was able to look at because when
he didn't take a three in the first half
that was crazy I mean he didn't have a
three he didn't have a free throw he's
averaging 10 free throws a game of the
22 that they take he's taken the threes
and really if they do maybe even some of
the open shots if they had him out of
have ten assists at half for his age a
game a team that's as good as Kansas but
we were at the walkthrough Kansas had a
great play
for him but to have that maturity and
have that ability to literally control
the game like he did in the first half
and then carry it into the second half
that just took another level of special
to me I mean it really did because
that's got to be your your level of
maturity possession after possession to
play a game that way when you can score
the way that he can but there were times
he was catching the ball you wasn't
looking at the rim last night and and
and they guarded him well but it wasn't
like he couldn't get shots and he just
kept moving the ball and an incredible
pace and he drove the entire energy up
of his team because of it you're exactly
right how much bigger is he going to get
or stronger or fill out I know his dad's
but you know bigger but you know he he's
he's kind of thin well I think a lot and
I think the one thing he's got now for
his age he's got deceptive he's like
there's some real curry qualities and I
think I think Steph Curry probably still
does have a deceptive quickness even
though he's been in the NBA enough that
people know but he had a deceptive
quickness at college he's got really
good speed he can play off either foot
which is easier said than done so he can
he can wiggle there was a play last
night that he took a shot fake gram got
into him he threw the ball and he was on
a dart moving on the pass cut and got a
layup like that's not easy and so an
answer to your question when you look at
his body especially when you see his
back like he's got a strong back he's
got a wide shoulder I think he's gonna
get a lot stronger I think he's gonna
get his legs are gonna get stronger and
I think he's going to get faster and
quicker just because he's already got it
and he's so young so I think I don't
think he's anywhere near becoming the
athlete that he's gonna be over the
years I've never seen him in the weight
room but I don't think he's anywhere
near that and I think he's just gonna
keep getting better and better it's a
fun listen last night coach I always
learned something and usually it's about
shooting when I listen to you and you
you said as Trey young came down the
floor you said watch for the slip screen
all of a sudden there's a slip screen
and you know manigott the hit that hit
the three so it was great call you know
you're Tony Romo impersonation
well they hadn't run that all game and
that Manik the thing that makes Trey
young and usually great point guards are
great not only because they can make
plays but because they always are
looking for their outlets and Manik is
one of the great outlet players because
he does such a great job that was a set
play but he does such a great job of
getting loose and and and moving without
the ball and he's going to be he's going
to be a household name in college he
would be right now if he probably
already is to most of the NBA scouts
that are paying attention to him but
that was a great play that kid executed
and what I love about young he puts that
ball right where you can shoot it all
you've got to do is release it safe
travels Tom thanks for joining us
absolutely thank you that's a Tom Crean
ESPN college basketball analyst for more
Dan Patrick show to the audience channel
239 on DirecTV or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]